man I'm trying to watch this Game of
Thrones and um and man these guys they
just I mean they cannot get along really
or the women
or the women so how does don't even know
what to think anymore I mean it's just
swords and pedophilia and they don't
even and what about all the candles that
are lit do you even notice that every
said everybody they got two thousand
they got nine candles everywhere
somebody's getting murdered and they got
three candles behind them who's putting
them out and you never see anybody you
know doing like a little bit of fire
safety or something protocol whatever I
gotta I gotta quit worrying about some
of this stuff
[Music]
every
[Applause]
[Music]
that you know but you still
me every night I lie awake I feel like a
fake I put on a show that is Jameson
flood like the water if you ever had too
much to drink and uh and that's similar
to a flood but it's different good to be
here um with you guys thank you for
joining me and thank you for allowing me
to be here with you what's up I'm here
you're here jeez sometimes I feel like
this I like I'm just leaving you a voice
mail and it's just like a really long
one like I'm this that chatty VM dropper
it is it is right now it is Monday June
10 the 10 of June so if you see somebody
tomorrow and I said well what date is
that you say well it's the 10 of June
it's the 10 of June and we are coming up
I believe on these summer solstice and
that's when summer really really starts
to heat things up and in the planets
like all agree that it's summer they
kind of line up and the Sun and the moon
and it's uh cuz there's always a couple
you know they always got to plan it or
to you know Pluto you know a couple of
Jupiter's moons or whatever that are
always like ah you know it's not summer
it's not really summer it's that you
know we're doing is
a couple holdouts but when that
Soulstice lines up when that summer
solstice June 22nd and that's the
equinox when it lines up that's when as
summer says that's the Grillet and
that's the time that real summer really
will [ __ ] grill you meat that's when
that fire comes straight out of the Sun
and just it'll get you it will get you
if you're trying to get rid of a spouse
or something that is a good time to to
you know to leave them in the yard so
but let's don't think about that Oh
what's going on I uh I'm a dad oh I had
jet lag I had jet lag
and look I didn't think jet lag was that
real and the death I'll be in the middle
of a mouthful of potatoes you know we're
patate and I shut down like somebody
pressed the power button on me while I
was patata
and I will just you shut down
jet lag will bring a man I mean it'll
make you ankles roll right out of your
feet it'll just it's a real thing and I
think it's something we can start to
find a way to use on our enemies a
little bit of jet lag but what do I know
we got a you know I'm happy to be here
with you what's going on with me what's
going on man honestly dude I hurt my
frickin back I was putting a shirt on
and it wasn't even a strong shirt or a
thick shirt I was putting on a mediocre
you know a mediocre shirt and I came out
my head came out the neck hole and it
came out like at an angle and I hurt my
back in my neck
so I've been just kind of real
limited-edition all week
I've been having to lay ice lay on ice
in my bed I'll get me a couple trays of
our ice and I get my mom I got a beach
towel and a beach towel
somebody really that's marketing cuz a
town well you could do anything with a
towel towel for this towel for that you
good you got out the shower towel up you
you know you spilled someone get that
towel you know you are you're in the
desert towel up put a towel around your
scalp you know they got it all then
somebody said oh we need a specific
towel for the beach we need a beach
towel and that's marketing right there
it's still a towel there's nothing
different about it somebody put the word
beach in front of it and now everybody's
[ __ ] spending an extra 1399 and I had
that beach towel I'll put it on my bed I
put a bunch of ice cubes up with three
trays of cubes on it and then I'll lay
on that ice and be that little ice daddy
that Ice Baby
and man it's cold at first but then the
pain goes away and you can't feel
anything and damn you get so cold
sometimes and then it disappears and
then you don't even know who you are man
and I even have to put my legs up in the
air looks like I'm a damn newborn like
I'm a newborn and I'm trying to get my
you know my bum powdered by mom I'm
trying to get my bum powdered by mom and
and so I do that and um I just been
icing and heating my back all week so
it's been just out of commission it's
crazy man everything's going good in
there BAM son get on your knees boy and
the pain - I don't you know I don't have
anything to subside the pain so I'm just
praying this [ __ ] goes away and they
don't have a chapter in the Bible really
about you know pain remedy the Bible
doesn't have a you know a couple hundred
milligrams of ibuprofen hidden in it so
I was going through all of these Ramadan
everything I'm celebrating anything this
week that will help alleviate the pain
I'm asking all the gods for help we had
a lot of calls that came in about you
know I like to think about when I was
young and just the joy and then when you
were young man and you you know you you
tried something new for the first time
maybe you saw you know you saw all
remember the first time you saw a peach
you're like damn it's an orange just
kind of like a it sound like a senior
citizen orange or something is that like
an orange that maybe been in a halfway
house or maybe a orange that you know
it's kind of like one of those hairless
cats but like it's like a hair it's like
a like it's like the hairless cat of the
orange family and somebody's like now I
[ __ ] that's a peach man there's
a pageboy
so you know you get I love being young
everything was a new experience and we
get older we get used to the experiences
and they start to run together and
they're just things you lose their
novelty and that's what I'm you know I
and I try not to get too caught up in
the fact of things losing their novelty
so I'm trying to just I'm trying to stay
in the novelty of life because there is
a lot of beautiful stuff going on and
and one of the novelties that we all go
through in time is when somebody touched
our in a wiener of you know up in a you
know if a lady somebody touched you down
in that trim trim you know in the down
and the Verger tans brought down and
them you know down in them uh down in
that you know in that freaking little
that you know down in a sugar wallet
down any old you know down any old
oyster all the old oyster coin purse you
feel me well everybody has a story about
that in a different moment in time and
we had a beautiful call about a year ago
lady first time a man ever touched her
vagina was in AE abandoned refrigerator
box out in the garage and she had a you
know she had a she had a beautiful story
about that and and we all have a special
first time and a lot of you guys know
first time somebody you know a young
lady over there off of highway 22 kind
of masturbated me out into the water
over there off the you know in one of
the tributaries of the Tchefuncte River
this Lady Jaye owed me out there into
the water and that you could see the
fish come up and get get the seed that
had come out of my body and that was
nature going full circle you know I mean
that is just damn nature like somebody
just put a whole bunch of nature in a
blender and just made a dam just a
smoothie just a soul smoothie and just
poured that [ __ ] right down into your
freakish chakras and and everybody has
that moment so a lot of you guys hit the
hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three and thank you for
for hitting the hotline and and you just
called in and shared some of your
moments all I want to hear some of those
I haven't heard any of them and I'm
grateful to you for sharing her pieces
of your life because we all remember
that time that first time cuz look when
you're young you've been touching young
crotch you know I remember we had a guy
in our area this boy this kid his name
was Tyson right they called him fat
Tyson and nobody his dad called him that
so and you know he would do you know
everybody would do he would everybody
when you got to know your body when you
find your body had different erogenous
zones in erogenous zone is something you
massage yourself a touch of nipples do
remember when your nipples got hard
remember that wow I didn't know what was
going on I thought I got like had fallen
down and got an acorn stuck like in my
Ted on each one double corn you know
so yeah just different times but I
remember fat Tyson told us one time that
he had he had hidden like a small one of
those toothbrushes you get into his eye
and it was honest and his you know
honest or whatever you know into that
that behold boy and this I know this is
getting kind of dirty but I'm just I'm
just letting you know that we all have
experiences with our body and there's
nothing wrong with that there's nothing
wrong with if you're young putting
something in your buttocks there's
nothing crazy about that I mean when you
first are born you learn about your
mouth that's a natural whole you know so
you put snacks in there put a sugar
Treat in your mouth put a little
cornbread you know put a broccoli or
something into your mouth
and that's natural then you start
learning about other you know you're
sneaking to mom's room one day and you
see dad in there doing a the ear cleaner
q-tipping and so you get one and you do
it at and that's crazy you can't even
imagine like if it's so close to my
brain this is scary and you pull it out
it's a little bit of browning and you're
like Jesus my brain has brown wax in it
I'm going to hell you know you get
caught up and then another you know then
you wean you you know your vagine or
whatever you get used to a new thing
your belly button I'm in one of my
favorite things I would lay on the floor
at night and put a couple chocolate I
will put a couple chocolate or chocolate
chips cuz Toll House used to have these
second chocolate chips when mom was
gonna make chocolate chip cookies she
got a bag of chocolate chips and she
would have to hide them because if I
found that sack of chocos to the dome
and so I'd take a couple I usually take
three and I'd put him into my
bellybutton and lay on my back about a
television watching in the heat of the
night which was a beautiful television
show and and uh and they would get
heated up by my body heat and that's
when that went in my butt my belly
button would fill with a little bit of
chocolate sauce or chocolate you know
kind of a mousse I guess almost a nice
fancy you know a mousse they called it
and then I would dip my finger in there
on a commercial break and get me a
little hit of chocolate and put that
thing in my mouth and just really just
eaten chocolate right out of my own my
own belly button which is unique because
you you know years earlier I've been
inside of my mother she had fed me
through that tube and Here I am filling
that hole you know that that same space
where my mother had once nourished me
Here I am melting chocolate chips
Tollhouse morsels and just morsel in
myself up just dipping my finger into
that melted morsel and just bringing it
straight up into my face you know
feeding myself now years later and
that's just full circle it's the same as
it's not the same it is very similar to
masturbating into a stream and watching
the fish come and they may be two years
later you're at a restaurant down the
street and you have a little bit of uh
you know some tilapia or some barramundi
oh you have a cut of uh of whitefish of
butter fish first of all we're where
they get new fish from you notice this
on menus every like maybe two years they
put a new it's like oh they got the
mahi-mahi where's that big did you go
read moby-dick see how many mahi-mahi
they got in that sucker
zilch ezel Chi brah go you know now that
I got the barramundi I'm somewhere the
other day and the guys like oh we got we
got line caught barramundi dude I don't
give a [ __ ] how you convinced that guy
you know how you convinced that thing to
swim over here I don't care if you
poured nicotine in the water for a
couple years and slowly got him addicted
you know what out what oh we got see you
know we got uh we got um you know we got
successfully convinced salmon like you
just convinced them to jump in there
than that it's just like what the [ __ ]
are we doing Newton and barramundi I
never heard of that
give me a real fish people have heard of
catfish swedish fish it's a candy but
everybody's heard of it
trout umm tuna fish
I'm just sick of some of this fake fish
[ __ ] every oh we got butter fish we got
whitefish what uh what are you talking
about where where'd you get it you got
an email from the Lord and they said
auntie we releasing you know two new
types of fish like it's a new shoe
you've got a limited edition over here
on these swimmers get out of here
anyway I'm going nuts man I'm actually
starving as well right now um anyway we
got some crotch stories let's get into a
couple of those and thank you guys for
for callin also but right before we get
into I want to say this too if you hit
on you know we have a couple shows
coming up Vancouver this week Vancouver
Seattle Portland Boise and we always do
things for single moms out there and we
have some tickets that we're going to
give away for each of those cities to
single dads it's Father's Day coming up
so it would be great if you guys would
email producer PR OD UC ER at Theo von
th EO vo in we want to do something
special for some single fathers out
there we've got and just email and
nominate a single father and this has to
be a father of decent age I don't don't
bring me some 79 year old 200 year old
guy who you know he has to drink through
a sack or whatever he's got a qalaat I
don't
that guy I want a dad who's got a young
child who has a child who's in school or
you know I'm saying I want a single dad
or and I know that's just my definition
of it but that's what I would like so we
want to do something special for those
men out there who because it's tough for
those guys to so you want to do special
for something special for some single
dads and that's what we're gonna do and
we want to thank our patreon supporters
for helping us with that set aside some
tickets so just email Theo von at
producer com if you recommend someone in
those cities and put the information and
we will uh we're gonna we're gonna give
out some some sets of tickets for those
different cities Boise Portland Seattle
and Vancouver and thank you guys so much
for your support
let's take this call right here we go I
feel this is Sara from Chicago hey Sara
from Chicago nice to see you over there
and Chicago an amazing city in the u.s.
you know a good City where I think you
get a little bit of everything and I met
some beautiful ladies over there in
Chicago and over the years I saved him
on my phone I'll be like Oh Chicago
Janet you know Chicago rain you know
raylene or rain l and then over the
years but then you come back to town
over the years and you then you hit him
love you're like I only remember now
this lady's you know she's 45 or 47 and
she got a couple kids her husband's text
me back like who the [ __ ] it what's
going on she got to be careful who you
whose number you save in that great city
let's hear more this morning on my way
to work I was laughing at the hotline
question because my first sexual
experience of a 15 year old was with
some with some cracks rubbing and praise
God babe
praise God and let's hear you just say
that part again about the crotch rubbing
because it just makes everybody heard it
I can't tell um with some cracks rubbing
and my boyfriend and I who is not my
husband we're in the back of my dad's
car on her
home from Great America oh we had so it
begins immediately I'm going back to
that place in my heart in my right now I
want to go put on like a um I want to
put on a big Johnson shirt they had this
special series of shirts I want to go
put you know I want to I want to put on
some old music some boys to men or some
some kind of [ __ ] and really make it pop
so you and your oh yeah you're in the
back and a parent's car okay let's go my
dad's car on our way home from Great
America Great America is in gurney and
you lives all the way in Chicago's it's
a good two-hour drive turn up the music
dad 35 and I remember I just kind of
started touching his crotch and I just
don't really know why oh I know why cuz
the Lord wants you to that's why I mean
us look if you put my hand somewhere and
you put a crotch somewhere else
and you turn off the lights when you
turn that light back on I swear to God
boy my handle mejia so let's hear more
I'm the oldest of two brothers so I
didn't really have any siblings that
kind of helped me understand what sex
was what was going to happen none of
that
so he started reacting his due to a
woman touching his crotch and he had a
he had a hard-on for about two hours all
the way from Grandma's opposite home and
my husband and I we still laugh about it
I remember being so shocked not really
understanding what the hell was going on
if he was going to be okay oh yeah and
that's beautiful and you know that's
love when you get erect and somebody
asked you if you're doing okay I mean
that's American love right there usually
you get erect and people woman might
laugh she might you know text to get a
shot of it a snap show her friend you
know Ronnie's got a little bit but it's
beautiful when a woman you know you get
a wreck you've been a wreck for a couple
hours a girl knocks on the door hey
everything all right let's hear more now
obviously it's something we can look
back if not that gang gang gang gang a
to our Weiner your man showed out with
and that's beautiful
and if you wanted to enter something in
a National 4-h competition they're
judging rabbits and they're judge and
you know little chickadees and stuff you
got to have two of the chickadees and
this hares got to be slicked back and
they got to be healthy and their sugar
levels good but you show me a man who
can have an erection you know a two-hour
Wiener
on a riding back seat of a car while his
while the dad is picking the music
that's a show animal to me thank you for
that call and thank you for that story
and just taking me back in time I
remember hearing the first time I've
ever even heard about people having sex
because we used to do some peeping tom
and when I grew up peeping tom and was I
mean that was cable and we used to do
some good peeping tom and block and see
somebody eat and I watched somebody eat
or do sex or whatever
and all of it was kind of the same to me
at all just I was so curious very much
like the American Beauty remember that
movie with Kevin Spacey and the other
boy
Ben Affleck or whatever but I loved that
uh I loved watching people live their
lives through pain glass who doesn't and
so what I'm saying now is this I don't
even know I'm saying I don't mean who
I'm talking about but uh but thank you
for that story thank you for taking me
back I remember the first time when I
was yelling hearing about sex and
hearing that people that were having it
and there was a boy and he was like a
year older than us or two years and
everybody said that he and this girl
that had sex on some lawn chairs I'll
buy a pool over summer and suddenly
everybody's like man people are scared
people are rioting I'm having sex on
pieces of paper and just drunk just you
know depending it to their shirt
remembers like what are you talking
about you know people didn't even know
like everybody was just consumed people
are buying lawn chairs and Lena laying
them just put them in their yard
other people are like sacrilegious
they're buying lawn chairs and like
putting gas on them and burning them
yelling racial slurs and stuff at him it
just it got wild but but yeah once that
fire starts once you hear somebody I
mean I remember my buddy my buddy you
know I remember the big thing was if you
could touch a woman's crotch while y'all
were in the back of the car when the mom
was taking you home that was and still
let me say this that is still a golden
move I don't care if you're 15 or if you
are 60 if your wife or your significant
others mother is driving y'all somewhere
and you in the back with your lady and
you get to doing some touching or you
know or they are your lady jerk you off
while your dad is driving y'all
somewhere that's still awesome man that
is still it's kind of like it's them
it's the Mount Kilimanjaro of sexuality
it's just that rare it's just that thing
it's something it's like so defiance of
your parents and at the same time so
like adventurous because with all your
dad has to do is turn back and look and
you are you're done dude ha ha ha one of
my friends who will name Nate who will
remain nameless he was with his family
driving somewhere on a vacation okay he
puts the map up like this and
masturbated behind the map I mean if you
think your parents don't know that
you're masturbating behind a map in a
small vehicle this wasn't an SUV this is
a car SUV maybe jerking off behind a
Rand McNally
[Music]
behind a small map in a car in a siddha
Han woo dirt that's dirt boy that's dirt
mm-hmm boy you gotta tighten up on that
look on that level all right let's take
another story that came in here but that
man just some beautiful stories
beautiful stories and we just wonder
what a phenomenal time this is in
people's lives well cos cows are you
from North Carolina man called in for
the SPC the SPC challenge yes sir and
that's first time Krotz touch and that's
that f first time ft CT crotch touch
thank you for calling in Kyle from North
Cal lack a beautiful beautiful place
over there and I know Duke was losing in
those in those to Vanderbilt in those
men's College World Series but kudos to
them for for developing a great program
over there I know you in season in the
College World Series as well right now
on whatever you want to call it at first
time crotch story first time I grabbed
crotch my parents and everyone else was
going to church and you know when you
put the Lord next to the loans it's a
[Music]
face-off Oh makes it more exciting
doesn't it when everybody was in church
we would sneak away and go upstairs and
we would swap spit with the girls you
know I was a middle school and I had my
girlfriend at the time and I seen my
step sister and her boyfriend do some I
never seen you hadn't touched your
crotch
they told me that's what you got to do
that's what you gotta do
boy
sorry this is a very interesting to me
to hear this research let's hear more
they were older than me so I went back
to Sunday school and I was excited you
know
oh yeah suddenly it's Saturday night
even though it's Sunday school suddenly
it is Saturday night my friend yes sir
let's hear more we have learned this new
trick and we were making out and I
touched your crotch so we get to school
now Monday I'm excited as you know oh
yeah you're damn Wayne Gretzky brother I
mean you're the damn Wayne Gretzky of
young league let's hear it and she has
sent me a note saying we were moving too
fast and she broke up with me and I'm
even grabbing his crotch for a few years
because I was kind of like a PTSD from
you know I thought every time I try to
make a move on anybody they were gonna
break up with me
wow man well appreciate you sharing that
man I couldn't understand that song yeah
you know look that's very look something
happens and then alarms you and then you
set off let's hear more but that's
that's my first cross story so Gang Gang
I love y'all what Gang Gang brother and
thank you for sharing your story with
everybody and I mean that you know it's
brave to put a little bit of yourself
out there whether it's a piece of your
past or a piece of your present and I
and I applaud all of all the callers
that do you know I remember now you know
I had a wrecked-tile dysfunction for
probably about 11 years and I still
really you know I'm probably still at
all times I gotta have a little bit of
gas station you know some of those GSW
PS as gas station Weiner pills in my
system at all times to even really get
out of bed in the morning I need two
milligrams of something running through
me and and uh and it's uh yeah [ __ ]
sorry for us time out Jesus
man yeah well so you I remember getting
non erect and a lady and then I try to
tell her like I was doing magic and I
was like tada my dick still wasn't doing
erection my Weiner was still being soft
me and you know real natural and she was
disappointed and then I couldn't get
over that for years because really I was
just nervous I should have just said hey
I'm just uncomfortable right now and it
probably would have been cool but at the
time I was just young and I was nervous
and there was broken glass and look I
can't get her right in your broken glass
okay yeah my bad right but I can't get
erect near broken glass and I still
can't or if there's a car accident or
something do you knife ain't I ain't
getting the erect near a car accident
okay yeah my bad ladies but yeah those
things really can give you a little bit
of travesty but thank you for sharing
man that is the middle schools a little
young to be learning that trick you know
first time I saw some breasts I remember
I was aw well they used to have somebody
had chiseled some tits into a nice birch
that had been hit by lightning out near
us in the woods and people used to go
masturbate to that and you know and
that's just the Lord working but this
was I was at summer camp and they had
this girl man she had red hair
I'd never seen red hair I've never seen
it I'd seen you know different colors of
hair brown blond black white
but I'd never seen red hair in this girl
had it managed she just looked so exotic
to me
and I saw him another camp counselor
looking at her breasts one time this
dude Joey I think his name was or you
know Joey was actually a little more
this dude Joey was his name he was my
camp counselor John he had a cousin a
nephew named Jonas oh okay for some
reason I know them and my brain my brain
is just skipping on their name but they
was out I think he grew up out awfully
roid anyway but they Joey I think was
looking at the lady's breast the camp
counselor and I was a camper a camper
and so I was like oh what's in there you
know and she kept looking in her shirt
and and they said Oh titties are and so
I wanted to look in right so I looked in
and I saw him dude and I've never seen
titties do to set for my mom's you know
and I'd only sneakily seen them and seen
him sometimes when I didn't want to when
my mom didn't think that we knew what
titties weren't she would on sometimes
she would just get out the bath and we
would seal but what happened was oh oh I
saw him and then I lied I said I didn't
see him
they were like what I was like yeah I
didn't see him you know so then they let
me look again and I looked again in
there and there they were again still
just milling around this see on this on
this camp counselors chest you know tins
and then I said oh I remember I said I
only saw one and that time they [ __ ]
said I was I was like a sicko and so
then I kind of felt like something's
wrong with me after that a little bit
and I was afraid to see both breasts at
once on a woman even though I'd lied
about it I was still like I'll tell
alive on something and then also suffer
the repercussions of my lie
in that crazy I'll be like oh yeah I
only saw one tit even though I saw both
they'll call me a sicko then I feel bad
Lyonne and then I'll also think for
years to come when I see tits and if I
look at both of them at the same time
something Bad's gonna happen to me
so Jesus Christ let's hear another call
that came in but Sunday school slipping
off from the Lord to do the devil's
handiwork as always a hotline is nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three here we go
this is a first crotch experience call
thank you for the call brother homeward
this is Sean from Boulder City Nevada
Sean o from Boulder City Nevada and I've
never been over there but um you know it
sounds beautiful rolls right off your
tongue Boulder City um I was about 13
between 7th and 8th grade I was prime
touch an area dude that's prime time to
touch a be touched you laying in bed at
night you can just hear other kids
touching each other's crotches and it
just burns you up let's hear more
brother onward it was in Springfield
Missouri oh yeah
this spring feel go I met this chick at
the swimming pool we go back to her
place you know
oh yeah and crotch always feels fresher
when it's right out of the city pool if
you ever noticed that or that summer
time pool the fur or out of a bathing
suit crotch always feels fresher when
it's fresh like that I'll quit
interrupting you homework we go back to
her place you know and to this point I
had only really seen late seventies
early eighties pornography oh yeah sorry
I told y'all wouldn't do that anymore
let's hear the rest of your story sorry
friend babies pornography so you know
I'm a lot of bush back in those days and
so for some reason I thought the little
that JJ was like an inch or two below
the belly button
I guess the hairline of the crotch and
so uh so you thought a woman was like
one of those those little gnomes as a
little belt with the jewel in her belly
dang man that's that's very interesting
I mean you would be a very unique
surgeon homework I was you know
searching around with the old index in
the fingers it man I was confused I
didn't know what was going on I didn't
know I [ __ ] around I got hermaphrodite
or something you know I was young but I
finally the girl gave me little
assistive help you go a little farther
down south and got my IFV easy never
really talk to her again
but yeah that was a high first class
experience set out a sprinkle Missouri a
public swimming pools r.i.p Billie
conforto were to keep your name in the
street
caring gay gang Brian thank you for
bringing him up man I appreciate that
dude yeah I was looking at some somebody
sent me some pictures of him the other
day actually and I should put some of
those on the onto the onto the this past
weekend and then we had a shirt designed
for him as well and so they will put
that out but you have a member that did
I remember something like that touching
thinking I was you know I didn't know
what that was just kept pushing on some
girls midsection that's crazy right just
put this just massage and some girls
Fupa or something who knows I mean it
was WOW when you were young I had a
buddy and he used to practice touching
girls on his own behold and at first I'm
like that's crazy but then I'm like I
can't fault this guy at least this guy
has a little bit of lay of the land I'm
out here wrote you know you don't know
what's going on then I remember thinking
that it was all a myth that girls didn't
even have vaginas cuz I remember laying
now with this one girl up there off a
half-million-dollar road and that's when
you know the pizza delivery guy had
crashed and a lot of people had robbed
him and [ __ ] but I didn't get involved
in that I was back at the house you know
trying to touch a little like that you
know trying to just get involved in that
womb tunnel you feel me get a little
into that womb and
[ __ ] I'm talking about but but anyway
man thanks for your story man thank you
for calling in brother for sharing that
story let's take another cross story
here we go hey Theo this is joy for
moleska Georgia just calling in to give
you my first Christ up story hey joy
thank you for calling in and you know
nothing brings joy to youngsters like
touching one another and and saw it's
just ironic that you called today and
thank you for being a supporter and I'm
excited to come over there to George I'm
excited to get into the South a little
bit later this year on some tour dates
and I'm gonna add some more and I want
to find some VFW chapters where we can
go and do some fundraising at some of
those places but I got a lot to do let's
hear more thank you for calling joy I
didn't mean to make that about me for a
second let's go three it's a long time
ago because I'm actually older than you
are so but oh look crotch stories have
no age okay though these things are
timeless let's go I do remember it
vividly because it was the summer
between all the 13 turning 14 and that
was back in a time where you know little
kids just rode their bikes everywhere
and hung out outside and did everything
all like that during the summer time and
I remember there was probably about ten
of us hanging around on our little bikes
and we had gone to this little area
that's the back of the neighborhood
oh yeah the back of the neighborhood
what goes on back there nothing good and
everything good let's hear more and just
throwing like some blocks in a creek and
stuff these two boys pull up on their
moped and back then you know I came from
an area where oh yeah the French we call
them Frenchmen let's hear more whoo boys
pull up on their mopeds and back then
you know I came from an area where that
was fancy stuff so the fuel and actually
looked at me and he was like his boys
about 15 he looked at me and he was like
um hey you want to ride you want to try
riding it and I'm like oh yeah hell yeah
never been on a moped jumped on the back
wrap my arms around them and we took all
forever
young for ya sorry you just got me do
you wanna ride in the backseat Oh Eddie
you got me feeling all of this right now
you know boot-scootin biggie
you got me feeling the past suddenly all
of a sudden let's hear it on the back
wrap my arms around them and we took off
now that's the first time I've ever felt
something you know shaking them between
my legs and stuff like that so already
and I've got these little cute little
flimsy bike shorts on but it was already
feeling kind of crazy plus I got my arms
around this cute boy well we hit a bump
and all of a sudden this boy decides to
just slide his hand
take it off one of the controls slide
his hand back behind his back and just
grab ahold of my crotch now at first I
was alarmed but at the same time it was
one of the first time I've ever had that
feeling about do I like this or do I not
[Music]
so needless to say I was squealing by
the time I got off of that moped and I
guess the moral the story is I did like
it whether I wanted to admit it at the
time or not and mopeds are fun to ride
at times so anyway that's my first crush
story Wow Wow thank you for sharing that
story it's like boy that crotch is it's
like a it's like
you ever see if you ever be in a
neighborhood or something you get to a
certain aging you realize oh there's a
power plant or there's like a power grid
or area in our neighborhood or you you
drive by that place for years you don't
know what it is looks like some weird
wiring and this fence is outside do not
enter do not enter and then one day oh
that's electricity that [ __ ] that's that
that place kills monkeys and commercials
years ago and that now that is the crush
that's that thing that's that
electricity that's that hug that's that
NASA I'm it's all space it's all space
and then you got that NASA just north of
yassuh you feel me that's that crotch
and it's really remarkable it's really
really remarkable to hear that story of
you on the moped a French a French mode
of transportation and the boy reaches
back I mean what a what a Power Move
there and also love how you're not a fit
you're not like oh this got molested
mean that's it nowadays people lose all
of their [ __ ] but the person who is
involved in it they see what's going on
oh I meet you know the guy it seemed
like it was just your experience and
that's what happened you could decide if
you liked it or not you weren't sure it
was just a moment where we kind of
decide the guy didn't you know trappy or
nothing like that or put you in a kennel
or anything like that it was just a
regular afternoon and I bet sometimes
you see a moped go by and you uh I bet
those feelings flare up for you and this
beautiful man is truly beautiful to
imagine and just to reminisce and to
think about that That's Life that's life
and and I think it
nice to be able to share your story and
also yeah it's funny cuz that those
thing at those ages things are happening
and we were deciding if we like them or
not do I like this am i okay with this
does this need to stop and this needs to
this needs to occur more what's going on
here
and that's sexuality that's how we
develop some of our sexuality is by
having experiences that are safe enough
where we could still learn and make
choices and and I know some people that
they have dark experiences but I'm glad
that we're sharing ones that are you
know at least ones where we're where we
were all in a space where we could learn
and have a moment of knowledge um you
know I remember and I got so many
stories about this now and I guess I'll
tell him a different time because I want
to get into more of an episode here but
I remember so we went to the dance when
I was in school I was a school child I
mean I was a school boy
a lot of people think I was always an
adult and that's insane that's insane
and uh and so I will I remember we went
to a dance and afterwards we went back
to my buddy's house and one of the gals
from the dance came out came back there
with us and my buddy ended up touching
her crotch and God dude I was so horny
bro damn I was on him boy I was horny I
mean I was like a like a tri hundred
Sara tops dude I was horny horny horny I
mean I'm surprised poachers didn't show
up and try to [ __ ] me up cuz I was on
and one mmm and my so do my buddy was
out and they went off in the woods and
they were being gentle with each other's
bodies like that and so then her mom
came in God or whatever I think her mom
was a cop or something she was out dawn
or out or something doing police work
and and I lived in this kind of place
and police sometimes would show up and
just shoot a gun into the woods a couple
times just empty of you know just empty
the clip right into the woods cuz they
figured if you out in the woods [ __ ]
around at night and you get shot you
probably deserved it you know you in the
dark woods so but yeah her mom came by I
remember and took her and you know he's
just the time her mom was gonna come
pick her up there was no issues or
nothing and then afterwards my buddy's
out there and I remember just putting my
I mean when they walked off in the woods
I remember putting my ear to the ground
and just I just wanted a hear as much of
this touch and as I could I wanted to
just be as close to it as I could I was
so jealous anyway they came back and my
buddy you know everybody was all excited
and that's when another kid's dad came
out to the we were standing about a
bonfire out there another fellas dad
came out there the boy's house it was
and he came out there and uh and he
ended up and this is a little bit
grotesque is it but it's also nature and
animals do this all the time
heeded up smelling my buddy's hand for
about 15 minutes out there my buddy's
dad and this is my friend who had just
walked off into the woods and touched a
girl's crotch for the first time and
then my buddy's dad came out and just
smelled my buddy's hand for probably not
15 minutes that's long primal nine
minutes and we ought to sat there and
watched him is Huff on this hand and
just
and that's nature boy in this nature
what else are we gonna do today oh yeah
we got Nick is gonna come in and talk to
us about the news a little bit and then
we'll get back into a few more stories
yeah but send in some submissions for
the single dads we're gonna do some
single dads tickets for them for some
shows that are sold out all those shows
are sold out and saved some tickets to
surprise some guys and yeah because I
just can't imagine what that's like and
I don't have that experience I don't
have a single dad but I mean I guess I
did after my parents divorced but I
didn't live with my father so I don't
have that experience but I can only
imagine that it's probably not that far
different than having a single mother
I'll say this Nick is gonna be in with
us in just a second so hold on all right
we got a nick is in studio how's it
going man it's going really good just
trying to get this studio working order
we're making it happen in the meantime
yeah man I want to thank you to demand
for just uh you know I know you guys are
I mean I know we're all doing it but
yeah there's a lot of space to fill here
yeah yeah that's not we got a little
frigerator that's cool yes some cold
waters we're getting there high fat
meats by piece um if you had to say like
on a hundred percent what percent are we
at right now you think considering the
most important function is being able to
do the podcast I'd say we're at 65%
that's good I would agree with that and
there's a lot of room for new
opportunity so probably 10% is room for
new opportunity yeah yeah and there's
like a percent that's always gonna be
available available because we're
constantly evolving so you'll never be
to a hundred percent
ideally Wow I think I like it now I
thought you're right yeah the goal of a
hundred percent is almost kind of crazy
huh yeah what do you do when you get
there just disappear into the ether yeah
yeah can't stop what are you gonna do
just disappear through a wall like Joe
Rogan does sometimes the cordon
- Nick Swardson you remember that yeah
he said he saw Joe Rogan eating ferret
sashimi and then disappeared through a
wall I don't imagine him disappearing I
imagine him busting through it like the
kool-aid that's you're like extremely
loudly disappearing oh oh that would be
so cool to watch a man and I yeah just
new construction Joe Rogan's
construction company would be so dope
it just takes down walls yeah
Nixon helped us with the news what's
going around the news let's see first up
with Toronto Raptors one win from
winning the NBA Finals point guard Kyle
Lowry is making headlines on and off the
court first he was chasing after a loose
ball you may have seen this jumped into
the stands and almost hit a lady she
moved out of the way but then a guy a
couple seats over like gave him this
extra shove he was really upset about at
the time and it turned out after people
looked into it that the guy who pushed
him was warriors minority orner mark
Stevens he's a venture capitalist and a
part owner so rich guy yeah real real
rich guy and Tuttle rich guy and he
ended up the NBA said he can't attend
anymore Finals games and he can attend
any more games until they complete an
investigation essentially tell people
stop talking about it sounds like and
that would be backward side and yeah I
don't know what are your thoughts on
that man a man first of all what about
his deferred the game when he comes back
imagine how nervous and awkward that's
gonna be it's like whenever you got in
trouble over something and you got then
you had to go back to the place and it
was always so uncomfortable you know
it's if he's a my he's a minority owner
I have to watch the tape again like I
think if someone if it's a reaction
where like somebody bowls over
somebody's just sitting next to me I
could have a defensive reaction you know
I've said I did see it a couple times at
first I didn't even notice what they
were talking about
I was like who's pushing I don't see
that part but but did it seem like more
than that to you I just felt like it was
unnecessary I kind of have a feeling the
guy might have had a couple drinks oh
yeah he was feeling feeling loose in the
front row but it's like I just there
nothing good can come from it I don't
know if you remember the the malice at
the palace that ye yeah Ron Artest
Stephen Jackson that brawl in Detroit
and it's because someone threw something
on the court and then the players react
and they're the ones that get suspended
for the season or worse you know yeah
that's a good point now Kyle Lowry if he
reacts
he's them he's the he's the bad guy yeah
it's like it's like I don't wanna player
players to dogs but it's like a child's
like new Nederland a dog and the dog
bites the kid right put the dog down
right yeah that's a good point that's
true those players have a lot to lose
especially in close proximity playing
out an intense game also a game where
they've had a lot of trash-talking you
got fat Drake over there you know you
know so sick of Drake oh dude it's like
what do you go play at least master P
[ __ ] audition to be on the team yeah
and show the road games yeah what are
you doing yeah you're just making it as
easy as possible so I think um I will
say I used to be a Drake fan but I'm
just kind of salty cuz I'm a pretty big
Milwaukee Bucks fan and he was just all
over that series and was he yeah it was
insufferable yeah I think just kind of I
mean ever since it's like even in his
early work when he's like the toughest
thing every went throw out the key
borrowed his uncle's car and brought it
back late or something and I was like
this is there's no street credit here I
think he's a good he's kind of like a
ballad singer more to me he's more like
I'm trying to think of somebody to
compare him to from he's turned into
more like boys to men yeah yep I agree I
agree which I was a boys to men fan so
yeah I agree I was a boys to men fan but
but I think that series is real chippy I
think if you're gonna let people set up
on the front and drink alcohol then they
could they could do things in women
think about definitely the guys in the
front row of those games they they feel
someone's like they are in the game
and the game almost feels fictional when
you're that close sometimes you're so
used to watching it on television then
when you're up close it feels like even
when I was at the MMA fights I thought
[ __ ] I'm like I could probably jump in
you know I could do this like as long as
I you know read the manual first
like other controls and know what x and
r to do and all of this then I could get
right in there
meanwhile the truth is if I [ __ ]
gotten up they're not gonna beat me from
behind before if I would have got in the
ring two guys would have beaten me so I
think a lot of people have that thought
though I was a big entourage fan back in
the day and Ari Gold he had courtside
Lakers seats and he was like he got
yelled at for stepping on the court and
he's like I paid 30 grand for these
seats I'll check in if I want to yes
it's the same thing I think people you
feel you have some entitlement like
you're part of it when you're paying
that much and you're sitting up there
right he has some entitlement I think
you're right that's a good word for it
so does it make yeah it doesn't make it
right I think the the the the punishment
will probably justify what happened I
think it will set some precedent but
also these these they run the risk
there's a fine line between how close do
you put people to the game they know
there's much you know in every half-inch
there's an extra $10,000 so they it's
like there must be a lot of insurance
and a lot of liability policy they have
their what else we got ma'am one more
thing or did you have any other thoughts
on it I just I don't know like like I
said the the player is the one that
stands to lose so I don't like it
shouldn't be allowed and I'm glad like
they shut him down now would you love to
see a net a separate game afterwards or
a fight afterwards the mine already
owners fighting each other on court at
half time let's do some real [ __ ] yeah
yeah that'd make them make the owners
play each other and then and then the
players can be at the stands that I
don't think they would react the same
yeah like I'd love to see some of these
snarky little minority owners out there
in their structure sweaters you know
have this side piece hold the Banana
Republic sweater that they're wearing
the v-neck
and and let them get out there and beat
each other at halftime get a couple to
j-cruise out there each other and have
Matt have them go at it but this brings
us to the next door story TMZ reported
that NBA teams and are discussing and
two have already done it they are
getting rid of the term owner who for
majority stake holders of the team
some people say because it's
predominantly African American players
there's some Rachel racial insensitivity
with the term owner mm-hmm what do you
think about that um
I think to this crazier where if you
rewrite the dictionary at some point I
mean I don't know dude uh but I it makes
me uncomfortable when I see people own
the people's rights to people on
television so I guess some of that I
could understand but if somebody's a
business owner and I'm employed at the
business then just because they have the
term owner I also have the term employee
I also have the term player I also have
the term father or you know whatever
your other terms are my brother I'm a
son I'm not just because somebody writes
an article and says that this that
you're still a slave or you're still of
this if you think that way that's you at
a certain point that's your own
mentality I agree I think it's just
ridiculous over over correction that
people are doing players like you said
their employees they own the team like
you own this podcast right I'm not
offended if you would have you don't
talk like that but if you ever said I
own this podcast I don't think take that
as you own me right but it's interesting
I wonder if with certain people would
you use certain would we use certain
terms differently you know I don't think
so I don't think it matter
it's just people making clickbait and
make in trouble and a lot of times it's
just lawyers like oh boy how can we find
another way to let's sue this way now
let's sue this way well let's sue this
way let's sue this way it's like it just
never ends I agree which raises
insurance rates people wonder why our
insurance is so high because they're
they allow lawyers to absolutely sue
every single direction and all these
lawyers that are like suing each other
they they're buddies the buddies and
they're buddies with the judge
and they just they're showing up for
another day of work with their friends
and it doesn't matter who's suing who
they're getting a piece of it
it's crazy man and at a certain point of
the everything can only go until it goes
and when he can't go anymore it's just
gonna get pretty real I think sometimes
it's alarming I hope so yeah so next
news story organizers in Boston are
planning a straight Pride Parade
tentatively scheduled for August 31st
the organizers are still working to
secure a permit from the city but they
just on Friday named former Breitbart
editor and controversial figure Milo Yi
innopolis as the marshal for the event
and he's homosexual man isn't he he is
yes who's always-- no pun intended
prided himself on fighting for straight
rights ironically right yeah I mean I'm
not surprised that they have people want
a straight prop right everybody once has
their own group now I feel like if
anything feels more under attack these
days it definitely feels like it's
straight you know even though a lot of
times they no one would write this
article or something because you know a
lot of the media companies seem to be in
the same group but I feel like if
anybody seems under attack these days or
if well here's what I'll say I have no
idea but to me it does feel like
straight men are under attack these days
that make you seem like if you're
straight that there's something wrong
with you then if you're straight that
you're also then anti-gay and that seems
to be like a narrative that's sometimes
out there that I don't like that much
also it's kind of uncomfortable
sometimes being a straight male a lot of
men will hit on you and if you reject
them in a way that even is kind or don't
then they will immediately call you
homophobic which is like I'm not
homophobic I just like women I'm not
homosexual so that's cool if you you are
I might be homosexual one day you know
if I do enough cocaine I could be a
homosexual for a little while in a
bathroom or something maybe but I don't
have any intention to be in full-time
gay male
not this lifetime in a way or not maybe
I mean who knows if when were 40 you
know the sugars or whatever we been
eating the riboflavin czar one of them
morphs you out next thing you know
aspartame
yeah aspartame dude and you out there
trying to tame some ass I mean it could
easily happen we don't [ __ ] know bro
people don't know the side effects of a
donut stick okay
you think you rely being in there every
morning get you that donut stick and hey
that thing doesn't have any side effects
boy okay so I'm not surprised that they
want to have that that they want to have
a straight prop rate I'm not surprised I
think it's okay look the cool thing
about America is any group should be
able to meet and just because a group
meets doesn't mean that it's against
your own group like a lot of people say
oh it's they're having a straight pride
that means that they hate gay or they
hate this or I don't think means any of
that maybe it's just some dudes that
want to [ __ ] have a good time
together I think I I think it's kind of
silly and like I don't know it's like
attention-seeking behavior yeah like I
mean Chris D'Elia had a great great
tweet about it he said straight Pride
Parade hey guys if you're in a parade
you're gay so which is a pretty solid
point maybe it's just me the closeted
men's parade what I don't like is if
they got this guy million appleís he
seems to be polarizing like his whole
thing is just to be polarizing I'm not
saying I agree or disagree with any of
his views I don't know even what his
views are but I think if you're going
for somebody polarizing then that makes
it kind of crit you know ad legitimizes
it a little bit yeah it's like you're
just trying to start trouble now if you
two got Ric Flair or something reduce T
roads out there [ __ ] whoo yeah sounds
like a party
it sounds like a good time I mean nobody
wore a beautiful woman's robe like mr.
Ric Flair he's kind of a bucket list
guest for me for this past weekend oh
man I'd love to have him who else why
you're in here man who else would you
like to get I've been seeing it from
mountaintops I want nor McDonald in here
I think you two together would be just
incredible Wow what's your buddy at
Amiga do it with me
you know what that's a great question
Adam owes me oh my god he just texted me
seriously yeah Norma had Adam who else
do I want so funny we just talked about
him
I would love Conor McGregor I mean
that's kind of pie in the sky he doesn't
do a ton of media appearances but yeah I
feel like he hates me for some reason
though I don't even know if you ever get
that feeling about Conor McGregor like
he hates you even though you don't know
him I think we'd be buds I'm pretty sure
I can but the Conor McGregor look-alike
it is well where'd you cut a regular
Halloween as well yeah a couple years
ago it's way too early no one knew the
[ __ ] he was you're just kind of like it
was 2014 no like a real thin lumberjack
Irish lumber get any other news uh just
a couple like kind of fun stories semi
fun
a Texas hiker was found alive after
missing for over a week that's Texas man
loving place people get taken care of
not surprised man yeah survived even
without the water 14 lions escaped from
a South African National Park let them
loose dude let him look I'm sure they'll
find room for him to live out here in
California you know sure let it loose on
the streets out here in California bring
them in or they are they rapist or they
can they read can they write are they
addicted to drugs who cares get them
over here I'm sure we can use them you
know well I'd love it it's gonna get
like that on the street soon people are
like free the animals from the zoos they
can't be caged up let anybody can live a
dr. drew said the other day that the
Black Plague is forming do you read that
I he's been talking about botch or
whatever it is blue Babu banach play
yeah I think that way it was it you're
right you're right he's like yeah it's
downtown is that what the smell of human
hearing
that's a 35 minutes ride from here we're
35 minutes headed over from the bubonic
plague different times thank you very
much you can follow him real Nick Davis
you have a podcast - Nick what is your
podcast oh that's awesome of you uh it's
uh sometime embarrassed to say it
sometimes it's only taken me about 150
episodes to bring it up me and a couple
buddies who work for the Adam Carolla
Show we recap the show The Bachelor
every week okay and the show is called
another bachelor podcast another
bachelor podcast so if you if you like
bachelor botched and botulism which is
headed soon to Los Angeles then uh then
you can check out the bachelor and it's
every week yep ever every uh we try to
get it out by Thursday the episodes
there Monday so yeah yeah another
bachelor podcast you can check it out I
will say very quickly if my favorite
comment we get people who don't even
watch The Bachelor tell us they listen
and they enjoy it really yeah yeah if
you look at our iTunes reviews because
our whole thing it's just a vehicle for
comedy it's it's si it's got a built-in
audience I tried to talk about the show
as little as possible when you heard the
podcast oh nice dude it's an interesting
show I mean David Spade Connors got me
into a recently because he you know he
always reviews it and he likes looking
at the chicks on there so if you follow
his Instagram story he's always just
like harping on it he's scouting is what
he is scouting I'm glad you noticed that
alright we got a couple more calls that
came in here the hotline nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three thank
you guys for putting up with me on this
episodes and just always on this podcast
you know I don't know what I'm doing
sometimes and you know it's weird it's
like sometimes I come in here and
you know I want to you know like I'm
scared of like oh I'm gonna say
something they're not gonna like me or
I'm gonna you know and I try to keep
those kind of thoughts out of my head
and just be myself if I can but
sometimes it's hard you know I know some
of us get scared I'm like what do I talk
about I don't know what to do and you
know what I do a lot of times when I get
like that
I just go
I just go I just go and just keep going
you know I'm not gonna do it right I'm
not gonna make everybody happy I'm not a
you know I'm not gonna make myself happy
[ __ ] half the time Jesus I mean if I was
happy person if I was you know happy
joyous and free if I was I don't even
know if I'd have this podcast you know I
don't know but I just want to just thank
you guys for putting up with me no
matter who I am and as I learn about Who
I am you know it's funny it's like it
really teaches me a lot about supporting
about unconditional support
and I hope that I can do the same for
you
you know whenever we have option ''tis
to do that in person or to do that over
the over the phone lines or whatever but
I just want to thank you for just being
supportive of me no matter who I am
sometimes because I didn't know that
that's really what what support is
support sometimes is being there for
someone to eat no matter who they are
you know they don't do what you want or
they don't behave so then what are you
gonna do you're just gonna you know do
we abandon people then
you know and you guys don't do that or
you know people don't do that for me and
so I just want to say thank you haha
some great stories some great calls
let's take another call here here we go
this was about feeling guilty about
things we spend money on we talked about
it last week a little bit
thank you know your last episode you
talked about your friend spending that
five deep take yourself on a vacation
and how we all kind of feel weird when
we spend money on know that saving I
know for me have a good job I make I
make good money I'm well I'm not been
able to save but I've noticed that I
strained a lot of relationships and I've
missed out on a lot of opportunities
Mike to enjoy myself but because I was
so focused on that financial saving and
you know what I don't want to spend that
money I'd rather just David mm-hmm isn't
that interesting you know it's tough
when you're hadn't really realized until
my friend brought it up and she's one of
my closest and dearest friends and when
she brought that up I was like wow yeah
it feels weird doing something special
for yourself that isn't like what the
norm says we need to do with our money
that isn't what the you know though
oh you got to do this and you got to get
that and you got to do that homework
I've missed out on a lot of things in my
life I've also noticed that it kind of
stopped me from being happy that could
be I'm trying to work on that gonna find
that that middleman you know prepare for
the future but also experience life
enjoy life so I'll you think people you
know you care about so funny things you
said anything you could kind of talk
about speed where was that middle ground
appreciate what's do about the talk now
thank you brother thank you for the call
you know I don't know as you're talking
I'm even thinking like man how scary it
is to be in a place of uncertainty
how scary it is to think oh well I don't
know what's gonna happen and we used to
live a little bit there more now we have
so many you know this everybody has a
calendar and everybody has like a plan
or a text and you know when the persons
arriving you know when they're gonna get
there and they used to be this thing of
I don't know that's why it was easier
then I think to have faith in a in a
higher power of any kind or faith just
in anything it just there was more
mystery in the air I don't know what's
gonna happen
but yeah it's why when you
the different you know I there was a
piece of art that almost bought it in
South Africa a few years ago and it
wasn't very expensive
you know it was I think maybe $350 and I
know that's expensive
but it was beautiful and instead I
bought this other piece of art for $200
and I didn't like the other piece of art
I don't even like it and they're
probably in the week that goes by that I
don't think about that beautiful
painting in South Africa that I could
have bought for three hundred and fifty
dollars and man I just didn't want to
spend that extra one hundred and fifty
dollars why well because I need that
money for this or for something or some
mutual fund or some [ __ ] or some I need
to be able to tell my friend across the
table when we're having dinner that oh I
got a new IRA or I got
why because somebody said that's what I
need to do there's a there's a there's
definitely a way to plan ahead but to be
not focused on the end I think and
somehow a lot of these advertisers and
stuff they have us focused on the end
and then we get there one like damn oh
yeah I'm all prepared for the end I got
money for this hospice I got money for
this but I knew every step of the way I
didn't take a risk I didn't take a
chance I didn't you know and I don't
have an answer you know cuz I do it
myself I'll play it safe a lot the only
thing I haven't played it safe with was
my career but I'll play it safe a lot so
I don't know that's a good question man
you know I don't know you know and
there's no right way to do life there's
no we don't know what we're doing and
you know that's something I heard
recently somebody say man I hope I'm
always a student and that's where you
know I want to try and stay as in the
space of being always a student if I can
and I know when I start to get him I own
ego on my own will I can really feel
when I start thinking I know so I hate
it man I get so sick of myself sometimes
you know when we were talking last week
about relying on others and and I and
that's it and then or about I don't like
working with other people when but then
sometimes I also don't like working with
myself you know and life is a middle
ground you know you're asking me what
that what's the middle ground
I don't know but man I bet it's a
beautiful place
yeah so I just want to thank you guys
for being a part of the episode I'll see
some of you this week in Portland in
Seattle and Vancouver in Boise
and yeah I'm just thinking like how do
we be brave enough to make choices that
might be different
to not know what that outcome is to tell
a truth that we're afraid is gonna
expose us for who we are scary it's a
really scary Menace it is all I mean
it's a game of Thrones but it's a game
of Thrones out here but sometimes we're
all the characters and we're the castles
and we're the dark corridors and we're
the you know so it just it's amazing man
we're all of it sometimes where the hell
is Westeros anyways it in Italy I'm
guessing I'm gonna I got a peep some of
that out
no maybe Newfoundland I don't know um
haven't ever even [ __ ] heard of it
the more I think about it what I'll say
is this man let's uh let's convene next
time I want to thank everybody that
called in with these magical stories
from their youth and and again we'll
leave out here on this song yeah I'm
gonna think a little bit more I realized
that when it comes to dealing with other
people I talked about this last week I
don't like to rely on others that was
the word that I finally found this week
we're relying I don't like to rely on
somebody else it scares me at the roots
of my radish this song is Jameson flood
every night I lie awake I feel like a
fake I'll put on a show
yes it's just life we're here thank you
guys
be good to yourselves and I'm gonna try
to be good to myself and thank you for
all the warm messages I get from a lot
of people when I'm not really doing well
and you know sometimes I there's been
there's a lot of letters and stuff I get
when I'm traveling I never read them and
it's not that I don't want you to think
that I don't care some of them I feel
like they're just you know it's to me
and so I don't know if that's okay to
share at a group level and then some of
them some of them are insane someone
were cut together with newspaper
clippings and [ __ ] I'm like this is this
could be this could be a murderer so but
this is Jameson flood every night
[Music]
every
that you know but you still
[Music]